when a group of teenage hackers started
to infiltrate Microsoft and it's xbox
video game division it may have been a
challenge and a thrill but it didn't end
so innocently members of the group were
accused of stealing massive amounts of
intellectual property and they faced
federal prosecution the story The Young
and the reckless is detailed in Wired
magazine this week and available on
newsstands this Tuesday we're joined by
its author writer and wired contributing
editor Brendon Koerner Brendon welcome
thank you first of all can I say that is
a really cool cover of the magazine
behind you there what attracted you to
this story specifically the first thing
was the scale of what was stolen talking
about 200 million dollars with
intellectual property at a low-end
estimate secondly the audacity of the
hackers was incredible to me the fact
they didn't just hack into companies
they actually organized a physical
break-in and burglary at Microsoft
headquarters to steal an Xbox prototype
they counterfeited their own Xbox
prototype console they really got stuck
into this enterprise the main character
that you talk about in this is David
pakora can you take us a little bit
through that journey going from as I
mentioned you're gaming and you're
enjoying it too then all of a sudden
something that's illegal ly someone
who's a born programmer at the age of
two he was playing a first-person
shooters on his parents PC at the age of
13 he was writing tools you could
actually alter the physics of Xbox games
wildly gifted but I think that his
curiosity and drive for a more and more
challenge drove him some pretty dark
places and take some pretty huge risks
you you write that he wasn't really
motivated by money you say that what he
most coveted
was the sense of Glee and power from
making 60 million dollar games behave
however he wished that's exactly right
so they did make some money in this
enterprise but it wasn't their top
priority they left
hundreds of thousands of credit card
numbers on the table they stole document
that would have been worth millions of
dollars to foreign governments or rivals
of Microsoft they didn't use those to
sell them they'd built prototypes in
their bedrooms instead for them it was
this thrill this buzz this kick of being
in their bedrooms and knowing that they
this gang of teenagers really was
running circles around these
multi-billion dollar companies it really
came through in the article that way
when you talked about them and that
intellectual curiosity they talked about
is there a way though to use this for
good let's say instead of what they were
doing so one thing that came across me
several times in talking to these
hackers was the fact that in school they
didn't feel challenged that if they were
fortunate enough to be in a school that
had computer science classes they were
way more advanced than their teachers
there's no after school there's no
equivalent of say elite athletics for
these kids so I think it's actually an
opportunity for industry and the
government to develop organizations and
programs to spot this talent give them
outlets given challenges to tackle and
then recruit these kids in to their
businesses or to other organizations
David procore was in his early 20s when
he was arrested I mean did they have
when they were in the middle of this
that they did they sense at all that
they might be putting themselves in
legal danger you know they really did
they talked among themselves all the
time about the fact the FBI was on to
them they were reading emails from
companies talking to the FBI saying that
someone's inside our networks we need to
investigate this and they weren't scared
by this to them it was a game until
things like wasn't till things went
horribly awry for a lot of them
unfortunately it's nothing new that they
had this capability we talked about
Packer conventions that go on but it
seems a little unique that you had this
group that was so organized behind it
how unique is that it's not really that
unique I think that when people who live
all over the world find each other
online and finally have common interests
that they don't share with people in
their local communities they forge a
kind of emotional attachment and bond
these people had a real friendship with
each other but ultimately they also
betrayed each I would say they sold each
other out yeah they did should we be
scared Brendan a group of teenagers
could do this I mean there's so many
concerns about cybersecurity now here's
another one sure on some level we should
be and it's a problem with network
security not just the fact that networks
are too porous there's too many flaws
and vulnerabilities but the fact that
once they're inside the networks we
don't kick them out yeah in this
situation you had these teenage hackers
get inside these networks the FBI was
aware and they still stayed in there for
months at a time
so access wasn't denied we need to
change our
about security and make sure we do
hygiene accepting people will get inside
we need to kick them out it was
fascinating when they were reading the
emails that the FBI was aware there
Brenden Koerner thank you a great
article great read